when you've grown up skipping meals in a
tiny little Crowded House sleeping on
broken mattresses watching your dad work
long hours for 20 grand tired every day
and then you're 22 years old and someone
Drops 400 Grand on you for playing a
game basically how does that make does
it make you happy you know what I mean
it's not it's not just my dad you know
what I mean it's everyone's dad I want
you know where I come from it's a very
immigrant area lots of kids who just
come over from Pakistan you know poor
families you know you go to and you see
them and the dad sleeping on the sofa
you know what I mean this is everyone I
grew up with when you give a lot of
money to a very poor person you
completely separate them from everyone
they grew up with you put them in a
situation where their life is
incomparably different to everybody that
they know to their parents to their
childhood friends to their
girlfriend and you force them to realize
that no matter how much money they make
everyone they grew up with is still
going to be poor